[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dear LeBron I'm sorry this had to happen
this way but I didn't tell you sooner
claiming the O'Brien Throne with you was
one of the proudest moments of my life
and I will be forever grateful for the
lesson
[Music]
I can no longer fight in your shadow
sure we had our differences but the real
problem is that were very much the same
many men succumbed to the law of rings
and super teams only to obscure a deeper
desire to be the man while this chapter
comes to a close a new door is opened
beyond which lies the knowledge of my
true potential I may find that I was
mistaken that I needed you all along or
maybe I'll discover that I'm more
powerful than I ever dreamed and so I've
set sail for the edge of the world but
if I find that this world is indeed
round
and maybe one day my journey will lead
me back to you
in my stead awaits another you may
recall his words from Nastya
well his wish has been granted there
will be a new king
[Music]
King James is late to his own meeting it
doesn't bode well for us getting out of
this slump hopefully he's finalizing a
trade for Kevin am i right
freaking Kevin
[Music]
you
[Music]